Вахтанже Костянтиновичу, протести в Грузії
очалися з того, що депутат Держдуми приїхав у Тбілісі
та сів у крісло спікера грузинського парламенту.
І вже через годину біля парламенту зібрався натовп.
Чому така реакція?
По-перше, його прізвище всі знають.
ін один з перших голосував за відокремлення Абхазії від Грузії.
По-друге, вже дуже багато наших загинуло там,
під час цієї горезвісної війни.
І по-третє, ніхто не знав, що вони приїжджають.
Є таке погане слово – "окупація".
І молодь кинулася.
Ну, хтось же посадив його в це крісло.
Я схиляюся перед цими молодими людьми,
які стоять там вже який день,
але поки міністр внутрішніх справ Георгій Гахарія
не збирається йти у відставку.
Але навіть якщо міністр піде, тема Росії залишиться...
Тема Росії - це вічна тема, бо це давно почалося.
Вона не нова. Там, в Абхазії і Південній Осетії, відбувається повзуча анексія,
кордон постійно пересувають, людей викрадають і потім просять за них викуп,
там ціла система...
Людина живе за парканом на одному боці,
а дружина похована на іншому боці,
і церква також на іншому боці.
І він не може ані піти до церкви, ані принести квіти на могилу...
Це все "мерзопакостно" - є такий вислів у росіян.
Який відбиток усе це накладає на ставлення
до російських туристів, які приїжджають у Тбілісі?
Усі туристи їдуть з Грузії дуже задоволені.
Досі туристів було багато.
Зараз Путін закриває повітряне сполучення,
але все одно я впевнений, що люди приїжджатимуть через інші країни.
Я весь час повторюю - у них дуже поганий, нікудишній сценарій.
А що це за сценарій? Це частина якогось плану?
Так, частина плану, ще 15-20 років тому
я дивився виступ Жириновського, як він розповідав
про план поділу Грузії на губернії,
а всі російські депутати слухали і аплодували.
І що це за план?
План у тому, щоб розколоти Грузію,
зробити так, щоб тут погано жилося,
і щоб потім росіяни сказали – ми вам допоможемо.
Тобто Кремль, бо народ ні до чого.
І вони увійдуть сюди, ось такий план.
Чомусь на нас все це зламалося?
Прибалти встигли піти. У Вірменії, здається,
дуже багато російських військових, а це поруч з нами.
Вірмено-азербайджанські перипетії теж всі звідти йдуть.
І ось так все закрутилося... Маленьку країну дуже легко занапастити.
А велику - складно. Не треба було їм лізти в Україну,
це не маленька країна, і вони свою батьківщину дуже люблять.
Це вже не маленька Грузія.
Ви відчуваєте безпосередню загрозу з боку Росії?
Так, звичайно, весь час...
У чому вона?
У тому, що люди живуть в очікуванні чогось дуже поганого.
І зараз це вирвалося назовні, тому така величезна кількість студентів вийшла на вулиці.
Вони дивляться на життя по-іншому, це треба враховувати.
Все ж у Кремлі уряд старих понять, а цей час вже минає,
давно почався рух в іншому напрямку.
Росію дуже дратує, що ми хочемо в НАТО, прагнемо до Заходу,
що ми хочемо бути демократичною країною...
Торік в інтерв'ю DW Ви сказали,
що ненавиділи герб Радянського Союзу.
Це спричинило шквал емоцій у Росії,
коментарі були дуже негативні.
Ви можете це якось пояснити?
Я ненавидів, бо в той час багато їздив за кордон,
і завжди помічав, що, коли люди дізнавалися, що ми з Радянського Союзу,
всі чомусь кривилися. Це відчувалося.
Нас завжди супроводжували працівники КДБ,
у зв'язку з цим серед артистів існує дуже багато історій.
Якщо тобі щось дарували, ти обов'язково повинен був здати це державі.
І загалом ми не відчували себе громадянами хорошої країни.
Єдине що я завжди говорив, що політика - це одне, а народ - це інше.
Але я знаю, що в Росії політика Путіна дуже багатьом подобається.
Тому що вони вважають, що він завойовує землі для Росії.
В один прекрасний момент це погано обернеться.
Не так все просто, що захотів…
У Росії люди ображаються, що ми називаємо їх окупантами.
Але як називати людину, яка забирає твою землю
і ставить там дротяні загородження? Це і є окупація.
Я думаю, він спить і бачить, щоб перетворити Грузію на Грузинську РСР.
Дуже хоче. А наша молодь цього не хоче.
Він - це хто?
Він це Володимир Володимирович Путін, директор Кремля.
Одна з учасниць протестів перед парламентом
сказала мені фразу: "Я не можу повірити, що ми
вже 30 років протестуємо проти одних і тих же дурниць".
Вона мала на увазі російський вплив у Грузії.
Але що робити з географією,
адже від величезного сусіда, який з півночі межує з вашою країною,
нікуди не подітися?
Нас дуже мало, країна дуже маленька, а він  дуже хоче -
він це Володимир Володимирович - дуже хоче посадити її на ланцюг.
І якби відбулося, в нас би не було цієї розмови.
Я брав участь в одному телемарафоні в Тбілісі,
і мене з Москви запитали: чому ви хочете в НАТО?
І чому Ви хочете в НАТО?
Вся надія на те, що у лідерів провідних великих країн
трохи защемить серце, і вони допоможуть нам увійти в цю коаліцію.
Наші хлопці уже багато років воюють разом з натовцями,
багато хлопців загинуло.
Але ось у нас неприємності через Росію,
так що, нас треба кидати, чи що?
Країна, яка називається Грузія, може дуже легко зникнути.
Але наші люди на коліна не стануть.
Що Ви думаєте про перспективи Михеїла Саакашвілі в Грузії?
В нього є ще один шанс у Грузії?
Складно сказати. Я знаю, що дуже багато людей люблять його.
Я знаю, що скільки б його не ганили, коли він ішов,
то залишив новому уряду дуже багато грошей у скарбниці.
А зараз, виявляється, в нас величезні борги.
Чому – ніхто не розуміє. Він перебудував дуже багато міст,
при ньому будували дороги. При ньому якихось шпигунів ловили.
Що він іще міг зробити? Я навіть думаю,
якщо він приїде, його будуть зустрічати в аеропорту,
я чомусь так собі уявляю його приїзд.
Що Ви думаєте про нового президента України Зеленського?
Він теж артист...
Я його дуже добре знаю. Він чудова людина.
Дуже освічений, дуже талановитий, інтелігентний.
Це інше покоління абсолютно…
Яке воно "інше"?
Інше - до чого ще не звикли колишні жителі Радянського Союзу.
Вони по-іншому мислять. Дай Бог йому здоров'я,
щоб у нього все вийшло. Я дуже цього хочу.
Ви могли б собі уявити політичну кар'єру?
Ви теж артист, дуже відома людина, у Вас гігантська популярність.
Ви би пішли в політику?
Моя психологія не сумісна з цією професією.
Я міг би сидіти в кріслі, звичайно, і робити гроші,
отримувати якісь привілеї. А навіщо це?
З собою нічого не візьмеш. Всі ми туди підемо.
Повертаючись до Вашої популярності,
кби Ви зустрілися з Володимиром Путіним,
що б Ви йому сказали?
Я б сказав йому, що у нього дуже поганий сценарист.
Дуже. Неправильно це. Ми - два православних народи,
ми повинні навпаки бути дружні, а відбувається протилежне.
Скільки років Ви не були в Росії?
Уже одинадцятий рік закінчується. У жодному місті не був.
Чи не сумуєте?
Дуже сумую. Приходить дуже багато листів.
І що пишуть?
Що політика - це одне, а ми - це інше.
Але я від самого початку сказав, коли відмовлявся від Ордена Дружби,
коли побачив російські танки на нашій території,
що мені буде соромно дивитися онукам в очі.
Тому що внуки виростуть і плюнуть тобі в обличчя.
Але я не думав, що така реакція буде -
дуже багато гидот писали в інтернеті.
У чому тут парадокс, Путін отримує в Росії
на виборах 76 відсотків голосів виборців.
Тобто більшість країни підтримує президента.
В Грузії, коли розмовляєш з людьми, всі чітко розділять –
окремо політика Путіна і Кремля,
а окремо - ставлення до пересІчних людей.
Але ж існує зв’язок між великою підтримкою Путіна на виборах
і його політикою.  Виходить, більшість росіян підтримують політику Путіна?
Дуже багатьом росіянам це подобається.
Вони ваважають, що він завойовує для них землі. Люди так влаштовані.
Мовляв "натомість він повернув Крим".
Наче українці забрали в них Крим.
Свого часу росіяни самі подарували Україні цю землю.